hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live schön dass ihr heute wieder
mit dabei seid wir schauen heute wieder
auf den Krieg in der Ukraine und die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive die läuft
mittlerweile seit fast drei Monaten aus
den USA gibt es jetzt Kritik an der
ukrainischen militärtaktik die Truppen
sein falsch verteilt deswegen gehe es
aktuell nicht voran fakt ist die Lage
bleibt weiter unübersichtlich zuletzt
vermeldete die ukrainische Seite aber
wieder vermehrt Gelände Gewinne so
hätten es Truppen geschafft in der
Region saporicia in den Ort robot in den
vorzurücken das sollen unter anderem
diese Bilder zeigen die ihr jetzt seht
die wurden von der ukrainischen Armee
veröffentlicht gleichzeitig meldet Kiew
Kämpfe in der Region krakev und dann
nett die Stadt in der Ukraine könnte zum
zweiten Mal von den russischen Truppen
eingenommen werden und wird deswegen
aktuell evakuiert dazu spreche ich
gleich mit meiner Kollegin Anne Brühl
die war bis vor wenigen Tagen in dem Ort
wie also ist der Stand der Kollegen
Offensive aktuell überrascht die Ukraine
ihre Kritiker sogar vielleicht mit einem
zeitnahen Durchbruch und wie sind die
Erfolgsmeldungen aus der Ukraine
tatsächlich einzuschätzen darüber
spreche ich gleich mit dem
militäranalytiker Oberst Markus Reißner
und wie immer gilt stellt direkt gerne
eure Fragen hier im Youtube Chat teilt
eure Gedanken zum Thema mit uns oder ihr
schickt sie per Mail an die Mailadresse
die eingeblendet seht ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche dann
so viele davon wie möglich hier im
Stream unterzubringen so und in Wien
begrüße ich jetzt Oberst Markus Reißner
der ist mir zugeschaltet hallo Herr
Reisner
guten Abend herzlichen Dank wieder
Einladung und liebe Grüße aus Berlin
sehr gerne bevor wir inhaltlich
einsteigen gestellt meine Kollegin
ankratzieren Ann-Kathrin Hecker Herrn
Reißner einmal kurz vor
militäranalytiker Historiker und aktiver
Soldat Oberst Markus Reißner analysiert
den russischen Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine seit dessen beginnen Reißner
leitet seit September 2022 die
Forschungs- und Entwicklungsabteilung an
der Theresianischen Militärakademie in
Wien und ist Kommandant des
österreichischen gardebataillos zuvor
von 2004 bis 2013 war Reisner Teil einer
Spezialeinheit des österreichischen
Bundesheers in dieser Zeitnahme an
verschiedenen Auslandseinsätzen Teil
etwa in Mali der Zentralafrikanischen
Republik Bosnien und Herzegowina Kosovo
Schatz und Afghanistan
es gibt also aktuell Meldungen dass die
ukrainischen Truppen in der Region
saporisia in den kleinen Ort robotine
vorgerückt sein welche Informationen
haben Sie darüber
ja die Informationen die uns vorliegen
und auch die Bilder die wir vor allem
aus den sozialen Netzwerken beiderseiten
sehen also quasi aus den russischen und
aus den ukrainischen vor allem zeigen
dass tatsächlich um diesen Ort sehr
heftige Kämpfe toben und dieser Ort hat
davon deswegen eine Bedeutung weil er
ein Ort ist der quasi das Ende der
sogenannten gefechtsverposten Linie
definiert das heißt hinter dieser
gefechtsverposten inne kommen dann
wirklich die hauptstellungen derer 3
sind bis sie sozusagen
ausgebaut ist und man erhofft dass die
Ergebnisse jetzt dieses Vorstoßes dazu
führen dass man diese gefechtsverposten
in ihr durchbrochen hat und mit den
Angriff auf die hauptstellungen beginnen
kann
setzen uns gerne einmal mit ins Bild wir
haben jetzt gerade die Karte
eingeblendet gesehen in welchen Regionen
wird aktuell am heftigsten gekämpft
ja für die Zuschauer müssen wir ganz
kurz zu Vereinfachung dieses Jahr lange
Form von 1200 km unterteilen wir können
sie unterteilen in die sogenannte
Südfront das ist also entlang des
snapers im Raum kerzone wo es immer
wieder Versuche davor Stöße von
ungarischen Seite auf der südlichen
vor allem dazu die russische Seite
abzulenken durch den Einsatz der Kräfte
dann der Zentralraum das ist der Raum
und den es tatsächlich geht aufgrund
dieser beiden Vorstöße einmal nördlich
vom elitopol und einmal nördlich von
mariopol da wird es so seit 83 Tagen
seit dem 4 juni heftiges gekämpft mit
bis jetzt nur wenigen Kilometer dann
vorstoßen also bis zur 10 km und da gibt
es noch den Nordosten dieser langen
Frauen und das ist der Raum von Pack Mut
bisschen wo ebenfalls gekämpft wird die
Offensive am 4 Juni hat im Prinzip an
drei Stellen losgeschlagen einmal im
Raum südlich von Bad Mode da zwei
Vorteile dass die Russen sich nicht so
tief eingegraben haben im Zentralraum
und den Zentralraum hat man versucht
einmal werde ich davon mir genannten
Städte bei Mario bolognitopol
vorzustoßen mit der Absicht das
Abschneidens sind das Teil ist der
russischen Kräfte quasi einmal in dem
Bereich SAP Person und Grimm und einmal
in der Nordosten und das Dilemma ist das
trotz der intensiven heftigen Angriffe
der Ukraine ist bis jetzt nicht
geschafft worden ist tatsächlich ja
substanziell vorzustoßen substanziell
heißt vor allem einen sogenannten
operativen Durchbruch zu ziehen das muss
man sich vorstellen wie ein Damm der
schlussendlich bricht und dann alles
mitreißt und diese Effekt ist noch nicht
erzielt worden
das sieht der Oberbefehlshaber der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte Valerie
solutioni bisschen anders als sie der
hat im Wall Street Journal gesagt man
stehe kurz vor einem Durchbruch ist das
ihre Einschätzung nach wirklich so
ja da darf davon nichts vergessen dass
der Krieg natürlich vor allem auch im
Informationsraum geführt wird und hier
ist etwas geschehen da in der letzten 14
Tagen dass ich sehr ungünstig für die
Ukraine darstellt das war der Umstand
das vor allem in den englischsprachigen
Medien und hier vor allem in den
amerikanischen Leitmedien Washington
Post New York Times
politiko vorabs ist immer mehr kritische
Berichte gab wo es in Frage gestellt
worden ist ob diese Offensive
tatsächlich das Ziel erreicht und wo
auch sehr aktiv hinterfragt worden ist
ob die Ukraine das richtige machen unser
solution hat jetzt das einzige richtige
gemacht der hat versucht in die
Offensive zu gehen und hatte so zwei
bemerkenswert die Dinge gesagt das erste
hat gesagt er möchte bitte ganz klar
formulieren dass man ihm nicht erklären
soll wie sie ihren Krieg zu führen haben
und das zweite ist dass er gesagt hat
dass möglicherweise dieser Vorstand
tatsächlich kurz vor der Tür steht und
es ist auch interessant das vor kurzer
Zeit auch der amerikanische
generalstoffe magmühle gesagt hat dass
diese erste Linie durchbrochen ist diese
eben von mir als gefechtsverbossen in
der bezeichnete Linie fakt ist aber
natürlich dass das der Historie
betrachtet von militärischen offensiven
man davon ausgehen kann besonders
langwierige offensiven die nicht
substanziell zu Ergebnissen führen am
meistens eingestellt werden und die
Frage ist ob das jetzt möglicherweise
auch die ukrainischen Offensive droht
denn der Faktor Zeit spielt zurzeit
gegen die Ukraine sie hatten mehr wenige
Wochen Zeit bis die nächste Regenperiode
die nächste Schlammperiode kommt und
dann steht der Winter vor der Tür
ich würde gerne mit Ihnen im weiteren
Verlauf des Streams auch nochmal darüber
sprechen wie eine mögliche wie die
Gegend Offensive der Ukraine
möglicherweise in Zukunft noch
erfolgreich werden könnte vorher will
ich aber noch mal ein paar Zuschauer
Fragen mit ins Boot holen und zwar fragt
dicke bei Youtube wie würden Sie die
Schlacht von robotie nee die kleine
Ortschaft über die wir schon gesprochen
haben auf strategischer taktischer
operativer Ebene bewerten die kürzlich
mit einem ukrainischen Sieg endete was
sagen sie dazu
ja da müssen wir bei der taktischen
Ebene anfangen die taktische Ebene
beschreibt im Wesentlichen das Kämpfen
der Verbände miteinander und was sie da
versucht quasi hier durch Manöver zum
Beispiel sich gegenseitig aus zu
manövrieren und dann Ergebnisse ja zu
erzielen und da ist es ganz klar so dass
aus taktischer Ebene die Ukraine in der
letzten Wochen es geschafft hat die
Russen zurückzudrängen aus der
gefechtsverkostenlinie und mit der
Einnahme der Stadt robotine so wie es
schein tatsächlich auch diesen
taktischen Erfolg erreicht haben auf
operative Ebene ist es so dass dieser
Erfolg auszuweiten wäre ihnen Durchbruch
also dieses Situation wie ich vorher
erklärt habe mit einem Damm der bricht
und quasi alles mitreißt also nichts und
rechts auch die Front von
opportunier quasi ausgesehen und das ist
noch nicht Erfolg das kann sein dass
dieser Druck der sich jetzt in der
letzten 24 Stunden erhöht hat man geht
davon aus es gibt also Bilder wo
dutzende mechanisierte Fahrzeuge hier in
das Gefecht gebracht haben
möglicherweise diesen operativen
durchbrenner ziehen können wenn das
nicht der Fall ist dann bleibt es nur in
der taktischer Erfolg und strategisch
wäre es natürlich optimal wenn aus
diesen operativen Durchbruch tatsächlich
eine Situation ent stehen würde wo die
russischen Kräfte geteilt werden würden
denn das ist das Kalkül das würde dann
die Russen möglicherweise eine
Verhandlungstisch zwingen und würde sie
dazu zwingen tatsächlich aus dem
besetzen Gebieten abzuziehen so kann man
also das grobe einordnen
vielen Dank für den Moment wir sprechen
uns gleich noch mal und wollen dann auch
die Frage stellen wie eine ukrainische
Gegenoffensive wie die tatsächlich in
der Zukunft auch erfolgreich werden
könnte wir wollen jetzt aber einmal in
die Ukraine schalten zu meiner Kollegin
Anne Brühl die ist aktuell in rakife und
mir jetzt zugeschaltet hallo Anne du
warst bis vor wenigen Tagen in der Stadt
im Nordosten der Ukraine da haben mal
knapp 30.000 Menschen gelebt die Stadt
könnte jetzt zum zweiten Mal von den
russischen Truppen eingenommen werden
und wird deswegen gerade evakuiert nimm
uns gerne einmal mit ins Bild wie laufen
diese Evakuierung gerade ab
ja seit der neunten august haben die
Behörden diese Evakuierungen angeordnet
die Bevölkerung ist aufgefordert die
Stadt zu verlassen und bis jetzt sind
ein paar hundert vielleicht ein bisschen
über 1000 Menschen dieser Anordnung auch
nachgekommen das läuft dann so ab dass
verschiedene Hilfsorganisationen
freiwillige reinfahren nach kohjanske
Adressen Anfahren manchmal auch
Sammelstellen die Menschen oft dann hier
nach haarkiff bringen manchmal direkt
gehen die dann weiter zur Familie zu
Freunden manchmal auch nach not in
Notunterkünften wir selbst der wir
konnten mit dem Roten Kreuz einmal nach
reingehen auf so einer evakuierungsfahrt
kurz vor der Stadt hält man an da liegen
dann auch die Freiwilligen ihre Westen
an haben die Helme parat weil sie eben
genau wissen wie gefährlich diese
Missionen sind immer wieder werden diese
Helfer auch von den Russen unter
Beschuss genommen da hat es auch schon
eine Verletzte gegeben man versucht da
so quasi so schnell wie möglich die
einzelnen Adressen abzufahren die Leute
einzuladen teilweise stehen die mit
gepackten Taschen vor dem Haus schließen
dann noch mal die Hoftür ab und hoffen
dass sie irgendwann dann doch wieder
nach Hause zurückkehren können
ich habe es gerade gesagt du warst bis
vor wenigen Tagen da du hast natürlich
auch mit vielen Menschen gesprochen die
da Leben ich habe gesagt es waren mal
30.000 jetzt sind es logischerweise
deutlich weniger wie was haben wir die
Menschen erzählt wie wie hast du die
Stimmung in kopians erlebt
ja also vielleicht muss ich das einmal
richtig stellen ich war dort aber dann
eben
Stunden weil es einfach zu gefährlich
ist wirklich lange dort zu verweilen und
in dieser Stadt kann man eigentlich auch
kaum mehr von Alltag sprechen und ich
kenne kopians weil ich im Dezember schon
mal da war im März schon mal da war im
März zum Beispiel gab es noch ein
relativ normales Leben da gab es einen
Markt da gab es Einkaufsmöglichkeiten
die offen hatten Menschen die auf den
Straßen unterwegs waren und jetzt wirkt
diese Stadt wie ausgestorben man sieht
eigentlich überhaupt keine Zivilisten
mehr auf der Straße es gibt wir haben
auch keine offenen Läden oder so gesehen
es ist wahnsinnig viel Militär unterwegs
ukrainisches Militär logischerweise und
immer wieder wird eben von den Russen
die sehr sehr nah angucken ganz heran
gerückt sind auf einige Kilometer wird
in dieser Stadt hineingeschossen und man
hört ständig diesen Artillerie Beschuss
und wenn man mit den Menschen spricht
dann nehmen die das tatsächlich so ein
bisschen hin also
wir sind da teilweise zusammengezuckt
weil das einfach sehr laut war sehr sehr
bedrohlich sehr nah und die Menschen
sagen auch wir wissen schon wohin das
fliegt wir sind daran gewöhnt wenn es
schlimmer wird dann gehen wir mal in den
Keller also das ist schon sehr
merkwürdig dass so mitzuerleben
du hast trotz dieser von dir
beschriebenen gefahren auch Menschen
betroffen die sagen sie wollen bleiben
auch wenn jetzt möglicherweise das
Szenario vor der Tür steht dass die
russischen Truppen dort wieder
einmarschieren warum
ja das haben wir sie auch gefragt und
die Antwort ist eigentlich immer ähnlich
ein Mann hat gesagt er ist aus einem Ort
der noch näher an der Front lag auf der
anderen Seite von koopians und er möchte
nicht ein zweites Mal wieder weggehen er
möchte da jetzt in Kopien ausharren ähm
oft sind es auch alte Menschen die uns
sagen sie haben eine kleine Rente sie
haben nicht genügend Geld alles hinter
sich zu lassen das sind Menschen die oft
kranke Angehörige pflegen die überhaupt
nicht transportfähig sind die ihr Haus
nicht verlassen können und die Menschen
sagen uns auch immer wieder das ist ihre
Heimat oder das ist meine Heimat ich
möchte hier nicht weg und auf der
anderen Seite sind dann eben diejenigen
die gehen die eben schon mal diese erste
Besatzung der Russen erlebt haben gleich
zu Beginn des Kriegs die Wochen lang in
Kellern aus gehabt haben Keller das ist
hier eine ukrainischen Häusern oft nicht
direkt mit dem Haus verbunden sondern
irgendwo im Hof da gibt es keine Heizung
das ist kalt dass man im Dunkeln die
Keller werden oft zur Einlagerung von
Lebensmitteln genutzt und das hat die
Menschen dann sozusagen auch gerettet
weil sie sich sozusagen aus die von
ihren Vorräten ernähren konnten zwei
Frauen haben uns gesagt wir saßen da
wochenlang es gab kein Brote wir haben
Wasser aus dem Brunnen getrunken als
zweites Mal stehen wir so was nicht mehr
durch und deswegen haben die sich dann
evakuieren lassen weil sie eben auch in
einer freien Ukraine leben wollen so
haben sie uns das gesagt
eine Brühl vielen dank dir für diese
Eindrücke live Austrag gif Dankeschön
also bisher ist es den russischen
Truppen offenbar nicht gelungen die
Stadt wieder einzunehmen der ukrainische
generalstaat hat gestern abend
mitgeteilt dass man russische Angriffe
dort bisher erfolgreich abwehren konnte
die Frage ist wie lange noch und was
brauchten die ukrainischen Truppen um
tatsächlich weitere Erfolge vermelden zu
können darüber spreche ich jetzt wieder
mit dem Oberst Markus Reis nach hallo
noch mal nach Wien
hallo liebe Grüße aus Wien also wie
gesagt die Stadt geplant konnte wird
aktuell evakuiert die russischen Truppen
konnten sie offenbar noch nicht wieder
einnehmen für wie wahrscheinlich halten
sie das dass die Russen dort wieder
einmarschieren
ja die Kämpfe um die Stadt kommt ganz
muss man in einen gewissen Kontext
setzen zu den Ereignissen entlang der
restlichen Frontlinie und so ist es so
dass Sie sich vorstellen müssen die
beiden gegnerischen Kräfte prallen
aufeinander und es gibt ein hin und her
aber keiner kann also durchbrechen und
was tut man man versucht an anderer
Stelle was ebenfalls einen Ansatz um den
Gegner was sie dort entsprechend zu
treffen das ist das was zum Beispiel die
Ukraine versuchen im Süden bei Personen
wo sie mit diesen kleinen Anwendungen
versuchen die Russen zu zwingen Reserven
zu verlegen damit der Druck im zentral
und nicht zu groß wird und genau das
gleiche machen die Russen sie machen es
im Raum nordostwärts sind dann diese
frontine nördlich von Bad Mut bisschen
auf in den Raum die quasi jetzt gerade
die Stadt gerade Thema war hier sind
interessant dass in den letzten Monaten
substanziell immer wieder Kräfte aus
Russland herangeführt worden sind man
kann das ist ja sehr detailliert auch
anhand der Typen die sie hier verlegt
worden sind vom Fahrzeugen sind das war
zum Beispiel also ein Kampffahrzeug der
wurden nach unter anderem in der
sogenannten die ersten gadepanzer mit
zusammengesammelt und diese Formation
plus andere Teile wie zum Beispiel auf
der 6 kombinierten Armee das sind diese
Einheiten die jetzt in die Offensive
gehen die russische Seite hat uns
natürlich nicht angekündigt dass diese
Offensive passiert einerseits zur
Tarnung aber auch zweitens unter der
volksdruck nicht zu groß zu machen es
ist aber tatsächlich so dass in den
letzten Wochen diese Einheiten Stück für
Stück Meter für Meter vor marschiert
sind und jetzt mittlerweile vor der
Stadtgruppe 1 stehen wo schlussendlich
jetzt auch die Zerstörung von Brücken
bei der Stadt ein Indikator dafür sind
dass es eine gewisse Dynamik entsteht
und diese vakuierungen zeigen auch dass
die Situation durchaus brenzlig sein
kann ob ein Durchbruch gewinnt so wie er
quasi von den ukrainen in Zentralraum
sehen wird das ist der fraglich weil
auch hier scheint es so dass Russland
also nicht substanziell genug Kräfte hat
um einen derartigen Durchbruch zu ziehen
aber man kann es natürlich nicht
ausschalten und das macht die Situation
bei Gruppe anzubringen und gefährlich
denn die Ukraine wäre dann gezwungen neu
Reserven hinzulegen diese aber im
zentraler und brauchen würde um ihren
Druck entsprechend zu verstärken um
diesen operativen Durchbruch
optimalerweise bis zum sommerschmerzen
strategische Ziele zu erreichen
dazu passt gute Frage die wir bei
Youtube bekommen haben von Wolfgang
Durst der fragt wie ist die Kampfkraft
derzeit verteilt zwischen der Ukraine
und zwischen Russland kann man das ins
Verhältnis setzen
ja es gibt grundsätzlich im Militär zwei
Begriffe Kampf Wert und Kampfkraft das
eine ist ein quantitatives
beschreibender Gäste das andere ist es
auch die Qualität hinsichtlich der
eingesetzten Waffensysteme der Morales
Soldaten und so weiter und so fort und
hier ist es so dadurch dass der Krieg
jetzt schon so lange dauert über 17
Monate man das Problem hat dass auf
beiden Seiten eigentlich die besten
Soldaten mittlerweile gefallen oder
verzehrt worden sind und dass die Lämmer
ist dass sich auf beiden Seiten nun
Reservisten gegenüber stehen Reservisten
die zum Teil schnellausbildungen
erhalten haben im Falle der Ukraine auch
durch NATO Trainingsmissionen aber auch
im Falle der Russen durch durchaus
Einheiten die zurückgekommen sind von
der Front und es gibt hier eine gewisse
paritätserkräfte und auf der anderen
Seite haben wir die vor allem Quantität
die sich auch ungefähr gleich darstellt
aber hier gab es auch vor einigen Wochen
mittlerweile die Aussage eines hohen
us-generals der gesagt hat dass die
Russen mittlerweile das Doppelte von
Kräften im Einsatz haben wie ein Beginn
des Krieges die Ukraine hat natürlich
versuchte nachzuziehen aber diese
Faktoren Kampfkraft und kein Pferd haben
nicht dazu geführt das ist zu einer
Veränderung vor allem im Sinne der
Ukraine gekommen ist die zu einem
durchgeführt haben und das ist das der
Lämmer Untergrund warum dieser Krieg
einfach immer weitergeht
eine weitere Frage die uns bei Youtube
erreicht hat lautet mich würde
interessieren für wie sattelfest Herr
Reißner die zweite und dritte
Verteidigungslinie der Russen hält sind
diese besetzt oder müssten Kräfte
zusammengezogen werden bei einem
möglichen Durchbruch
ja das ist die große Frage die sich
natürlich alle Stellen es ist so dass
argumentiert wird dass wenn also die
Ukraine diese gefechtsverpostenlinie
durchbrochen haben und dann auch
möglicherweise die erste
Verteidigungslinie dass die andere
Linien leichter zu durchbrechen sind vor
allem weil die Russen ihre Kräfte
bereits vorher verbraucht haben und weil
sie nicht mehr genug mobile Reserven
haben um diese zu besetzen das kann sein
muss aber nicht sein rein militärisch
objektiv betrachtet gibt es momentan
keine Indikatoren dass das der Fall ist
es ist sogar verwunderlich dass nach 83
Tagen heute haben wir den 83 Tage Beginn
der Offensive die mit dem 4 juni
festgelegt worden ist es bis jetzt immer
noch geschafft wird weil sie selbst in
dieser gefechtsvorposten Linie diesen
Abwehr Erfolg zu erzielen der sich jetzt
zu scheinst zumindest bei der genannten
Ortschaft etwas verbessert hat wie die
ukrainische Seite
wir haben also aus anderen Beispielen
des Krieges immer wieder auch gesehen
dass die Russen in der Lage waren eine
Art der mobilen Verteidigung anzuwenden
das heißt mobile Verteidigung bedeutet
vor allem dass man kräftig in der Tiefe
bereithält und diese rasch heranholt das
müsste man verhindern dazu braucht es
aber wesentliche Waffensysteme um was
sie dieses heranholderreserven zu
verhindern und dazu gehört unter anderem
natürlich auch eine funktionierende
Luftwaffe denn das ist genau das Mittel
um diese Bewegung des Gegners in diesem
Fall der Russen unmöglich zu machen über
die Luftwaffe und auch über die
Lieferung die angekündigte Lieferung der
F16 Kampfjets würde ich gleich gerne
noch mal mit ihnen sprechen sie haben
gesagt diese gegen Offensive der Ukraine
läuft seit 83 Tagen es gibt immer wieder
Erfolgsmeldung dann heißt es wirkliches
Vorankommen ist eigentlich nicht die New
York Times zitiert jetzt uS-Analysten
von denen es heißt die Ukraine verteile
ihre Truppen nicht richtig deckt sich
das mit ihren Analysen
und die Situation ist natürlich nicht
einfach für die Ukraine und es ist
natürlich so dass die ukrainischen
Soldaten an der Front stehen und dort
quasi den Kampf gegen die Russen führen
zu Befreiung ihres Landes und es wurde
schon sehr komisch an wenn dann aus der
Distanz man sie wissen lässt was sie zu
tun hätten oder auch nicht ich habe auch
schon oft versucht es ein bisschen
darzustellen mit der Schwierigkeit des
Geländes das Geländes sehr sehr flach
sie müssen sich das vorstellen wie ein
Schachbrett und die einzelnen Felder
sind geteilt von den anderen durch quasi
windschutzgürtel durch er baumlinien und
das Problem ist wenn man direkt von
einem Feld auf das nächste Ziel kommt
man in einen Abwehrkampf zwischen
panzerwerfen Kampfhubschraubern und
anderen Möglichkeiten gemischt und das
Problem ist man versucht jetzt sich an
diesen Randlinien also an den inzwischen
Linien der Felder quasi an und das ist
sehr sehr langsam aber es hat zumindest
substanziell soweit erfolgt das ist
ihnen gelingt langsam vor zur
marschieren jetzt da wenn man betrachtet
was in den letzten Wochen in der letzten
zwei Wochen vor allem in den
amerikanischen Medien geschrieben worden
ist so drängt sich einen Eindruck auf
dass man bereits auf der Suche nach
einem Schuldigen scheitern diese
Offensive ich denke darum hat er auch
gerade solutioni also generalstoffchef
solution versuchte den Angriff nach
vorne zu wagen vor allem auch um die
Moral der eigenen Truppen zu stärken
darum ist auch die Ankündigung der F16
so wichtig denn der Lieferung der 16 so
wichtig weil der Soldat an der Front der
quasi hier sich durch die Minenfelder
Vorarbeiten muss der hat das Gefühl
jawohl es passiert etwas wenn ich noch
ein bisschen durchhalte dann hat es
möglicherweise eine Entscheidung
Unterschied aber tatsächlich am besten
beurteilen die Lage das kann nur
rumänische Soldat und europäische
generalstoffchef vor Ort der diese
Truppen führt bzw der dort diesen Kampf
zu tragen hat
trotzdem sie sie beobachten der die
Situation auch aus der Ferne wie sie
sagen es gibt Berichte die die jetzt
nahe liegen dass die Ukraine tatsächlich
ihre Taktik in Teilen auch geändert hat
ich ist das was sie meinen mit sie
marschieren nach vorne ist es das was
ich mit ihren Analysen auch deckt
ja das bei einem derart komplexen
Unternehmen wie also das Durchbrechen
von gegnerischen Stellungen ist es so
dass eine ganze Reihe von Fähigkeiten
vorhanden sein müssen und diese
Fähigkeiten aufeinander abgestimmt zum
Einsatz gebracht werden was jetzt etwas
verklausuliert klingt bedeutet das
einfach einzelne Waffengattungen gewisse
Rollen haben diese quasi dann im
entscheidenden Moment des angegriff
durchführen müssen und diese Rollen wenn
Sie alle ineinander quasi gefügt sind
führen dazu dass es dann so einen
Durchbruch kommt am besten natürlich
nach wenigen Tagen der dann also dazu
führt dass die ganze gegnerische Form
zusammenbricht das war aber bis jetzt
nicht der Fall warum weil einerseits
aufgrund des Umstandes dass manche
Fähigkeit nicht vorhanden waren diese
z.B das niederhalten des Gegners nicht
möglich war und weil auch auf der
russischen Seite durch dieses
monatelange Eingaben ein
verteidigungsdispositiv vorhanden war
das in dieser Qualität seinesgleichen
sucht das gab es eigentlich das letzte
Mal im Zweiten Weltkrieg vergleichbar
mit zum Beispiel der Schlacht um Kurs
oder zum Beispiel bei der Wiener
Operationen Plattensee wurden derartige
Verteidigungsanlage eingerichtet dass
die Länder Ukraine ist das ist eben
nicht alle Möglichkeiten gemeinsam dass
sie nicht alle Fähigkeiten gemeinsam
einsetzen kann sondern aufgrund der
Waffenlieferung aus dem Westen immer
Stück für Stück einsetzt und das ist das
Problem denn die Russen können sich
immer wieder auf diese Fähigkeiten neu
einstellen und können Sie dann in Teilen
schlagen und das ist das Dilemma dass
die Ukraine hier quasi ganz klar hat als
solches
dann lassen Sie uns gerne einmal über
die von Ihnen angesprochenen
Waffenlieferung sprechen auch weil diese
Frage von unseren zuschauernden
Zuschauern kommt also Dänemark und die
Niederlande haben angekündigt der
Ukraine ab zum Jahreswechsel die ersten
F16 Kampfjets liefern zu wollen was
würde das tatsächlich verändern hier
schreibt auch jemand bei Youtube halten
Sie die Lieferung von F16 Kampfjets für
einen gamechanger für die Ukraine
nun kein einzelnes Waffensystem ist kein
Game changer die Zusammenschau der
Waffensysteme und die Zusammenwirken der
Waffensysteme das macht den Unterschied
und das ist das Dilemma das Problem ist
wir sind auch Opfer unserer eigenen
Propaganda ich sag das jetzt da so wie
es ist ganz hart warum weil wir uns
natürlich am Beginn des Krieges
eingeredet haben der ukrainische Soldat
hat mit der deutschen Panzerfaust in der
Hand die Russen aufgehalten da stimmt so
nicht das waren die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte und zwar die Streitkräfte
die am Land gekämpft haben in der Luft
zu sehen und auch im Seilbahn und einen
anderen Stellen wo die ist gar nicht
mitbekommen die waren verantwortlich für
diesen abwehrfolg sie wurden einmal
immer wieder abgenutzt und das Liefern
vom Waffensystemen hat ihnen die
Möglichkeit gegeben dann wieder in die
Offensive zu gehen so war es auch bei
dieser Offensive wenn Sie sich erinnern
gerade gesagt ich brauche noch einmal
300 Kampfpanzer sechs bis 700 Gramm
Schützenpanzer 5
Systeme zu gehen niemand hat eigentlich
gesagt dass nur ein Teil davon
eingetroffen ist also man nimmt dann
zwischen 50
60 Prozent im Wesentlichen denken Sie
nur alleine an die Leopards
zweikampfpanzer und das was dann zur
Verfügung stand das hat er dann
verwendet um in die Offensive zu gehen
aber es haben wesentliche Elemente
gefehlt wie zum Beispiel funktionierende
Luftstreitkräfte und es ist nun mal Teil
auch der Kriegsführung und folgt der
Logik wirklich so dass man wenn man
einen erfolgreichen Land Operation
durchführen möchte auch funktionierende
Luftstreitkräfte hat die den Luftraum
über den vorstoßenden Kräften schützen
bzw verhindern dass zum Beispiel so wie
geschehen die russischen Kampfflugzeuge
angreifen die russischen kampfhubwagen
Hubschrauber und Flugzeuge angreifen
können außerhalb der Reichweite quasi
der ukrainischen Flieger als Beispiel
und das ist das Problem wir liefern also
quasi an die Ukraine also der Westen
liefern die Ukraine und es konnte sie
immer Stückwerk herein und zu spät und
damit ist die Ukraine gezwungen das
Beste daraus zu machen und das tut sie
auch und versuchte hier langsam vor
zucken aber die Verluste sind natürlich
schwierig und dieses langsame vorigen
macht es den Russen immer wieder möglich
dahinter also hinter dem bereits
besetzten Stellungen neue Stellungen zu
richten würde das alles schnell rasch
auf einmal gehen also dieser operative
Durchbruch im Sinne eines Dammbruch ist
dann wäre das natürlich nicht möglich
das ist aber nicht der Fall weil die
Ukraine was sie hier Fähigkeiten hat die
sie dir nach wie vor fehlen und das
Lieferung F 16 wenn bei einer möglichen
neuen Offensive wieder alles
zusammengespart wird und dann gemeinsam
eingesetzt werden
okay ich wollte sie nämlich gerade
fragen sie sagen ein Waffensystem
alleine ist nicht der gamechanger aber
gesetz den Fall diese Kampf des werden
tatsächlich zum Jahreswechsel geliefert
was können die dann in dieser Gegend
Offensive bewirken
also gesetzt auf alles kommt zu einer
neuen Offensive zum Beispiel im Frühjahr
oder im Sommer nächsten Jahres dann wäre
es so dass zum Beispiel auch eine
gewisse Anzahl von Kampfflugzeugen und
hier ist wichtig zu verstehen das
Kampfflugzeug ist die Plattform es geht
also auch hier um den entsprechenden
Luft Luft und luftbodenwaffen dass diese
so aktiv wirksam können dass sie im
Falle zum Beispiel dieser möglichen
Offensive den Luftraum über den
geplanten Raum des Durchbruches sichern
und dafür sorgen dass z.B die
gegnerischen Kampfflugzeuge gegen
Kampfhubschrauber auf Distanz gehalten
werden und nicht angreifen können die
vormarschieren Kolonnen sie können aber
auch dafür sorgen dass sie mit
entsprechenden weitreichenden
luftbodenwaffen Kommando Strukturen des
Gegners sind in diesem Fall der Russen
angreifen Logistik Punkte angreifen oder
und das ist auch ganz besonders wichtig
dafür sorgen dass die Reserven die die
Russen heranführen wenn zum Beispiel
einen Einbruch passiert ist nicht diese
Einbruchstelle reichen sondern quasi
vorher schon zu einem Einsatz der
Luftwaffe kommt in diesem 16 und diese
Abwehr erfolgt das ist der Punkt 16
einbringen können unabhängig davon dass
natürlich durch die Verfügung von
Waffensystemen Kennzeichen sind auch
während des Konflikts in der
Vorbereitung also in der sogenannten
shaping-phase die wir auch jetzt ja
gesehen haben auch Maßnahmen getroffen
werden können dass der Gegner bereits so
geschwächt ist dass er beim Angriff
möglicherweise leichter durchstoßen wird
das heißt es macht sehr wohl einen
Unterschied
sie haben jetzt gerade auch die Luft
bodenwaffensysteme angesprochen eins ist
ja Taurus Marschflugkörper über deren
Lieferung in Deutschland immer noch
diskutiert wird welchen impact hätte
dieser Waffentyp denn für die Ukraine
ja ich möchte vielleicht ganz kurz
voranstellen ich möchte als Österreicher
mich nicht Anlassen also hier quasi
auszurichten was ist er hier ein
Waffensystem an aus Deutschland zu
liefern wäre und wie ihr so diese
eingesetzt wird ich kann Ihnen nur als
neutraler Beobachter mit einer
entsprechenden militärischen Ausbildung
sagen was man also herleiten kann also
wie ein Arzt den sie zu ziehen um einen
zweiten Befund zu haben unter daraus hat
natürlich schon einige Fähigkeiten die
zum Beispiel Skype und Storm Shadow das
sind jenes System geliefert worden sind
nicht haben zum Beispiel ist es so dass
die von mir genannten Systeme sich ja
besonders dazu eignen bunkerbrechen
wirksam zu werden also tief unter die
Erde einzudringen und dort Bunker zu
zerstören dazu haben sie einen
speziellen Zünder verfügbar und der
Taurus kann zum Beispiel hier variiert
werden das heißt er ist zum Beispiel
besser geeignet zum Angreifen die beim
Einsatz von z.B einer Sturm steht da
zwar getroffen werden aber sie haben nur
ein kreisrundesloch in der Brücken Decke
aber keine Zerstörung das kann total aus
mit seiner Fähigkeiten besser er hat
eine höhere Reichweite sein
Flugverhalten ist wesentlich günstiger
damit ist der schwerer Angreifer durch
die russische Flieger werden
Monaten laufen verbessert hat und
natürlich auch die Quantität der
verfügbaren Systeme macht ihr einen
Unterschied das heißt man kann also
nicht nur immer zwei drei Sturm Shadow
oder skalpaketen einsetzen mit dem
wenigen Plattformen die man hat sondern
man könnte quasi massierter vorgehen und
das Massieren da Kräfte bringt immer
noch den Vorteil dass der Gegner so
getroffen wird dass er sich
möglicherweise nicht erholen kann denn
von diesen kleinen Schlägen die zur
spektakulär sind kann er sich immer
wieder neu aufstellen und neu erholen
und das macht natürlich hier den Taurus
interessant für die Ukraine
ich glaube aus ihrer Analyse ist klar
geworden so wie es jetzt gerade läuft
wird es sich vermutlich noch lange
hinziehen und erhoffte Erfolge bleiben
dann möglicherweise aus wie kann diese
gegen Offensive der Ukraine ich weiß es
ist die eine Million Euro Frage aber wie
könnte diese gegen Offensive
möglicherweise noch erfolgreich werden
nun die Kriegsgeschichte ist voller
Beispiele wo ein Unterlage liegender
Gegner plötzlich dann einen Durchbruch
erzielte man ihm so nicht zugetraut
hätte und da Historiker hat dann die
Unart ihnen zu erklären warum das
genauso gekommen ist und warum es
logisch war es kann natürlich
theoretisch sein dass auch hier ein
eigenes eintritt dass wir so nicht
voraussehen können es kann sein dass
eine Eigendynamik entsteht aufgrund zum
Beispiel einem Durchbruch eine einzelne
ukrainische Einheit bricht plötzlich
durch es kommt zu einer Panikreaktion
die russischen Stellungen lösen sich auf
und man flüchtet so etwas gab es bereits
bei hakiv war genau das der Fall und die
Russen sind zurückgeflüchtet und wurden
dann bei aus Kiel das ist ein Fluss
quasi aber westlich von kubianski mit
höchster notwasser wieder aufgehalten
das könnte sich durchaus wiederholen das
ist ja hier auch das im Zentralraum
passiert und die russischen Truppen
zurückgeben bist doch noch oder
vielleicht sogar bis Melitta Pool es
kann aber auch sein das ist nicht
passiert und dass die Ukraine sich quasi
auch jetzt in der letzten Tagen mit
ihren Reserven übernimmt und diese
Reserven dann eigentlich genau diese
Kräfte sind die man brauchen würde um
sich zu konsolidieren um in den Winter
zu gehen und dann die nächste Offensive
vorzubereiten ja das kann man jetzt aus
der Ferne nicht sagen was man aufgrund
der Analyse der vorliegenden Videos und
auch aus den Analyse der sozialen
Netzwerke sagen kann ist dass es heftig
und intensive Kämpfe gibt dass die
Ukraine alles einsetzt was sie zur
Verfügung hat alles was er so quasi hier
auch vom Westen quasi an
ausbildungsunterstützung passiert ist
kommt also hier in diesem Fall jetzt an
wir haben also Waffensysteme die
eingesetzt sind die geliefert worden
sind und so weiter und so fort wir haben
auch die Russen die versuchen hier alles
dagegen zu setzen sie dürfen nicht
vergessen auch die russische Moral hat
sich zum Teil erwiesentlich verändert
die Stimmung in den russischen sozialen
Netzwerken ist ganz anders als das noch
bei Haki war oder auch bei Person
sondern nach den ersten brennenden
Leopard ich sage es Ihnen wie es ist hat
man also quasi schon gehört oder auch
nach dem brennenden breit ist also wir
haben auch das geschafft die werden das
jetzt weiter durchhalten wir haben jetzt
also ganz kleinen Kampf der Willen beide
Parteien sind ineinander verzahnt und
jetzt wo das Hin und Her das ist die
Frage wer wird sich durchsetzen und wie
wird es dann weitergehen
ich würde ihnen abschließend gerne noch
eine Frage von unserem Zuschauer Karli
Lukas Weitergeben der fragt wenn die
Regenzeit zurück kommt kann die Taktik
der Ukraine Lieferketten kommandosten
und Gerät anzugreifen weitergeführt
werden auch wenn alles im Schlamm
versinkt mit Blick auf den Herbst und
den Winter
ja das geht natürlich tatsächlich also
moderne Waffensysteme sind in der Lage
bei allen Witterungsbedingungen
eingesetzt zu werden auch bei extremen
Witterungsbedingungen und zum Beispiel
wenn er so der Flughafen ausgeliefert
wird dann kann er genau diese Lücke
schließen bis zur nächsten Offensive und
kann zu diesen abnutzungserfolg
tatsächlich ja mit sich bringen das ist
natürlich klar und auch möglich es ist
vielleicht auch wichtig zu verstehen
dass die Einschränkungen die sich
ergeben beim Einsatz zum Beispiel der
Storm oder auch das Haus nicht so sehr
die Waffensysteme an sich sind sondern
vor allem die Plattformen das Problem
ist die Ukraine hatten eine gewisse
Anzahl von Plattformen um dieses System
einzusetzen darum sehen wir immer nur
alle zwei Tage zwei drei Tage
spektakuläre Einsätze aber eben zu wenig
massiert um dem Gegner in diesem Fall
die Russen wirklich schmerzhaft zu
schaden so dass er quasi gezwungen ist
der Handlungen zu setzen und hier ist es
so dass gerade auch die die einsetzende
oder der beginnende Winter
natürlich genutzt werden kann von
Ukraine dieses Momentum weiter aufrecht
zu halten
sagt was Markus Reißner vielen Dank für
Ihre Zeit und für die Einschätzung danke
nach Wien
herzlichen Dank für Zeit und Vertrauen
und auf wiederschauen
soweit unserer ZDF heute live zum
aktuellen Stand der ukrainischen Gegend
Offensive wenn ihr dazu aktuelle Infos
haben möchtest dann findet er die findet
ihr die natürlich jederzeit wie immer in
unserer ZDF heute App danke für eure
vielen Fragen für die regelbeteiligung
und bis zum nächsten Mal ciao